Vincent: Hi, Jeffrey, and you need let's talk about the data screening project that you guys have of the project coming along.
Jeffrey Feng: Hi, do you?
Jeffrey Feng: We are a bit stuck with scraping some of the websites on our list. Some of them are dynamic, and I couldn't get the data we need.
Yooni Choi: Yeah, and i'm new to this tax. So I was wondering if you could help us out.
Vincent: Of course I will be happy to help. What specifically do you need help with.
Jeffrey Feng: Well, many websites seem dynamic.
Jeffrey Feng: so I was not able to figure out what to do if you scrape them. I used a few python libraries, but they are not returning me. What I want
Vincent: have you read into the library?
Jeffrey Feng: I have not.
Vincent: Selenium is a software, testing framework used to all the main web browsers. They can similarly user interactions with with the website and from automated testing to check for error
Vincent: performance issues and functionality twice for some of the website you were talking about.
Jeffrey Feng: Sure, my first action item will be
Jeffrey Feng: to read Selenium's documentation, then
Yooni Choi: so, Jeffrey, have you been using the beautiful soup library.
Jeffrey Feng: Yes, that's one of the Python libraries that I've been using.
Yooni Choi: I kept having installation issues. I don't know what is the issue. My, My my python version might be too old.
Jeffrey Feng: I'll help you with that. I guess another of my action item would be to help you with installation issues.
Jeffrey Feng: Could you update your python environment before that
Yooni Choi: that'd be great. Thank you. I'll update my python environment as my action. Item.
Vincent: Well, you are waiting for Jeffrey to help you. I think you can read it in your beautiful soups. Documentation
Yooni Choi: sounds good to me. I will make sure to read beautiful Soups documentation as my second action. Item.
Vincent: Good, Jeffrey, could you create a kid up branch? So we can. In fact, the progress of this project.
Jeffrey Feng: Sure, I can do that. My new action item is to create a Github branch. Then
Vincent: another action item for both of you, Jeffrey, and a unique is to report the progress tomorrow to me again.
Jeffrey Feng: Sure
Yooni Choi: sounds good to me, Jeffrey. Could we schedule a meeting later? So you can explain your previous code to me. I want to make sure I understand it.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, that sounds good. I will schedule a meeting with you as another action item of my
Vincent: all right, great. And for Touches action. Item, I will also add a new member to our team to help us with this project.
Vincent: I will send you all updating a week.
Yooni Choi: Thanks, Dr.